you good dude  are you good you you good  i know i know he did i i've been looking  i've had 9-1 dialed on my phone for the  last [ __ ] 30 minutes  just ready to press that last one for  you at any time  there was one point in time where i was  like i don't even know what the [ __ ]  he's looking at  did you yeah  are you with him too yeah no this i love  this guy but chris you  there were a couple times dude right  where i was like oh he's not paying it  he's  like if i'm here you'd be like this  and then out of nowhere you'd be like  and i was like  i don't know what show he's watching but  it seems fun  [Music]  come on board brother i've been right  there  that's why i'm asking you good he's good  all right  yeah what's your name man josh  all right man yeah  josh uh what's that yeah this song is  for you  uh it's not uh  [Music]  [Music]  you